you realize we're halfway through the
joke I guess that means I'm halfway
through my nap well well right now
you're about to see a man break a
world's record it's his own record and
it's for appearing on the Oscars show
more than anybody else an incredible 24
times was when you think about he's
probably appeared everywhere more than
anybody else he's been traveling the
world are making a laugh for 60 years
and even if we took the whole three
hours of this show it wouldn't be enough
to thank him for all the memories areas
and his record-breaking 25th appearance
to present the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award but I want to tell
you Bob Hope
thank you Thank You Alan thank you
he'd been saying nice things to me ever
since I did that Christmas show on the
set of mash but I'm happy to be here
instead it's my 25th time I think they
ought to give me an Oscar just for
attendance don't you but I'm happy to be
here at this annual Hollywood lottery
knowing that my house is Passover
and I love seeing Don Ameche made it I
think that's a beautiful thing
and he did it with breakdancing and all
these years I've tried to do it with
great acting
now first there was George Burns now Don
Ameche I hope it's a trend but I'm here
to tell you some of the credits of
Charles Buddy Rogers as an actor buddy
started in over 40 films both silent and
sound including the first oscar-winning
picture wings but Buddy Rogers biggest
role was as a humanitarian and that
commands our attention and our respect
tonight but he has given this time in
this effort generously to so many
organizations including the motion
picture and television fund the Jewish
Home for the Aged and the Hollywood
stunt man's Lupus Foundation the
National Conference of Christians and
Jews at which he's a member of the
National Board of Directors the Boy
Scouts of America the Navy League the
USC school of cinema the Los Angeles
Philharmonic in the USO buddies recent
honors include the 1985 special angel
award from child health USA the screen
smart set award for his work on behalf
of the motion picture country home and
he will be honored this year as st. Jude
hospital's Man of the Year every
Christmas but he has personally visited
the midnight mission on Skid Row and
entertained that the veterans assistant
lead Christmas parties if I list any
more you Lubich expect to him to come
out here wearing a halo but to these
organization and the people they serve
he's an angel to myself he's one of the
nicest people I've ever met personally I
think Jean Hersholt would have been most
honored to call Buddy Rogers his son in
real life it's a pleasure now to
introduce to you the man would be very
appropriate nicknamed Charles buddy
Rogers right here
yeah it makes me feel very happy to give
you this Jean Hersholt Humanitarian
Award right here I'm thrilled Bob thank
you thank you thank you thank you
right and I also want to thank the
Academy from the bottom of my heart you
know they say that old actors never die
they just lose their parts I haven't
lost all of my parts because this is the
best part I've ever had in all the years
that I've been living in Hollywood this
is my best part and if genes looking
down on us tonight
I hope he's pleased because I'm thrilled
I'm going to take this Oscar and take it
home and probably put it beside Mary's
two Oscars and Bob Bob I want to say
thanks for my memories thank you Bob
the show doesn't have to be funny to be
good well how's this code oh it's good